Eine schöne Frau macht
Werbung für ein Handy – Alltag.
Nur dass dieses Model kein Mensch ist:
„Shudu“ besteht aus Pixeln,
kreiert am Computer.
Sie und ihre Kollegen revolutionieren
gerade die Werbe- und Modewelt.
Echt oder Fake?
Im Netz wird es immer schwieriger, das zu
erkennen.
Bei Shudu und Co. war immer klar:
Sie sind rein digitale Produkte.
Doch immer öfter werden
auch reale Menschen gefakt.
„Deepfakes“ heißen Videos und Audios,
die durch künstliche
Intelligenz so manipuliert werden,
dass die Fälschung für Laien
nur noch schwer erkennbar ist.
Die Plattform BuzzFeed gehörte zu den
Ersten, die darauf aufmerksam machten.
Als eindrückliches Beispiel
diente Barack Obama,
der seinen Amtsnachfolger Donald Trump
einen Vollidioten nennt.
Natürlich alles Fake.
Präsident Trump ist ein absoluter Voll...
Was es braucht, um Deepfakes herzustellen,
sind Bilder, viele Bilder.
Ein Algorithmus analysiert
jeden Gesichtsausdruck,
jedes Muskelzucken und setzt dann etwa
Mundbewegungen neu zusammen.
So gelingt es,
dass auch lange Verstorbene wie der
Künstler Salvador Dalí wiederauferstehen
und Selfies mit Museumsbesuchern
machen – wie hier in Florida.
Oh, là, là!
Die schöne Seite der Deepfakes.
Möchten Sie, dass ich Ihnen das schicke?
Doch 96 Prozent der Deepfake-Videos
im Netz sind pornografisch.
Und nahezu immer trifft es Frauen.
Berühmte wie Scarlett Johansson,
aber auch unbekannte:
Die Australierin Noelle Martin
entdeckte durch Zufall Tausende
Fotos und Videos von sich im Netz.
Jemand hatte ihre Facebook-Fotos gestohlen
und ihren Kopf in
Pornovideos hineinmanipuliert.
Das hat mein Leben massiv erschüttert.
Wenn dir so was passiert,
hat es lebenslange Folgen für deine Karriere,
für deine psychische Gesundheit, deine
Beziehungen zu anderen Menschen,
deinen Ruf und deine Würde.
Martin versuchte, die Inhalte
löschen zu lassen. Vergeblich.
Sie ging an die Öffentlichkeit, erreichte,
dass die Manipulation von Bildern
in Australien nun verboten ist.
Doch sie kämpft weiter.
Unsere Gesetze sind nur begrenzt wirksam.
Was wir brauchen,
ist eine Art globale Vorgehensweise,
denn es kann nicht sein,
dass es im 21. Jahrhundert möglich ist,
dass jemand an seinem Laptop
auf der anderen Seite der Welt sitzt
und die Leben von Menschen zerstört.
Facebook hat 2019
einen Wettbewerb ausgelobt,
um eine Technik zu entwickeln,
Deepfakes aufzuspüren.
Preisgeld: zehn Millionen Dollar.
Eine ähnliche Initiative kommt vom
US-Verteidigungsministerium,
denn längst ist klar:
Deepfakes bedrohen
nicht nur Privatpersonen,
sondern den gesellschaftlichen Frieden.
Situationen wie der Sturm auf das Kapitol
könnten durch Deepfake-Videos leicht
zu einem Krieg eskalieren,
befürchten Wissenschaftler.
Zusätzlich zu dieser politischen Polarisierung,
wo sowieso schon unterschiedliche Gruppen
gegeneinander aufgeheizt [aufgehetzt] sind,
wenn dann Falschinformationen
dazukommen mit ’ner Technologie,
die ’ne emotionale Ebene anspricht,
mit audiovisuellem Inhalt.
Man weiß nicht, haben die politischen Gegner
jetzt wirklich zu Gewalt aufgerufen
oder bestimmte Dinge gesagt.
Da ist nicht die ... das passiert ...
Medienkonsum nicht in ’nem ruhigen Umfeld,
wo man schaut:
Was stimmt, was stimmt nicht?
Also da, glaub ich, kann es schon sehr
verheerende Effekte haben.
Hinzu kommt laut Bressan die Gefahr,
dass Menschen irgendwann
automatisch davon ausgingen,
dass Medieninhalte falsch seien,
je weniger sie zwischen real und Fake
unterscheiden könnten –
katastrophal in einer Demokratie.
Die Technologie verbieten?
Unrealistisch:
Längst nutzt die Spieleindustrie sie, um
Avatare der Spieler zu erstellen.
Auch Hollywood setzt große Hoffnungen in
die Technologie.
Denn Deepfakes können eine faszinierende
neue Realität erschaffen.
Schließlich war es noch nie so einfach,
David Beckham in neun Sprachen
vor Malaria warnen zu lassen.
Malaria ist nicht irgendeine Krankheit.
Es ist die tödlichste Krankheit,
die es je gegeben hat.
Und immer noch tötet sie
alle zwei Minuten ein Kind.
Ihre Stimme kann helfen, Malaria auszurotten.
Erheben Sie Ihre Stimme und sagen Sie:
Malaria muss ausgerottet werden.